i'm going to vietnam and i'm bringing a
beer
are you ready
what are we doing
we're going to run for our lives
we're halfway home halfway i'm chicky
donahue and i am not supposed to be in
vietnam
hey get your ass out of bed you lazy bum
look at you sleeping your life away
look at these scumbags
hey you're embarrassing yourself and
you're embarrassing your family do these
protesters not know that our soldiers
see that on tv i'd like to go over to
vietnam track down all the boys in the
neighborhood and give them a beer i
could do that do what bringing beer he's
not serious he's hammered look at him
the man's stoned sober that's his fifth
beer maybe tops i'm going to vietnam and
i'm bringing him beer
hey chief no chance you have a ship
heading to vietnam 1700 hours tonight
it's not gonna be easy but i'm gonna
show them that this country is still
behind him you're gonna get yourself
killed over there it's like you said
everyone's doing something
i'm doing nothing one morning
smuggling beer into a war zone that's
not the smartest thing i've ever heard
of it's certainly not the worst either a
new day
what if you start up here with collins
just came to deliver a sudsy thank you
card and then if you're still alive
you american new york thanks a lot
you can hustle down to dugan
[Applause]
tricky i brought you beer
you shouldn't be here you think this is
funny
i'm not doing this for laughs i'm doing
it for all you guys
come on time to go
is it over
yeah you're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't get it do you chick this isn't
a john wayne movie well you know the
good guys on you know the bad guys are
i didn't come all this way just to quit
somebody's got to be here to see what's
going on
i want the truth told
for them
they're just kids
you're going to find out it's a lot
harder to get out of a war than it is to
get into one i'm trying to show them
that somebody back home is still behind
her
you got a good heart chickie it's your
brains i'm worried about
[Applause]
who's this [ __ ] it's my next-door
neighbor he brought me a beer
hey
[Music]
you